- Looks like this is our...
- Okay, yes.
Oh, thank the Lord, okay.
(Williams)
'Hey, baby, what's going on?'
Bravo,
thank you so much for coming.
So, here's what
I want to make sure
you all understand right now,
right off the top.
I called you
to report a crime
that I don't have
nothing to do with.
- Okay?
- 'Well, this is a first.'
I'm not involved in the crime
I didn't perpetrate the crime
I didn't do anything, okay?
I was--
- Can we get to the crime?
- Yes, ma'am, yes!
I was minding my, I was
walking down the street, okay
and I was, indeed,
I'm not going to lie
I'm a vagabond, a bit
I'm a little bit of a vagabond
I was looking for shelter.
I found this vehicle,
the window was open
and I climbed in.
I climbed into the car.
Okay, so, you called us to tell
us that you climbed into a car?
Yes, and I looked in the trunk
and there's something
in the trunk
that I think may be
of interest to you.
So, I made sure that
I called immediately.
- What's in the trunk?
- It's... There's a head.
There's a head in the trunk.
There's a head.
Twenty-three-year-old male head.
Hypothetically, if I
had severed the head--
- Yeah, let's get to that.
- If I had done it...
- Okay.
Then...
What would the repercussions be?
- Hypothetically?
- Just hypothetically speaking--
- If you had done it?
- Let's say...
Let's say I was not me.
Let's say I was a different--
Let's do...
Let's play role play.
You be... You be you.
- We gonna be us, okay?
- Okay, I'll be me.
We would be, like, "Hold up."
Stop, freeze, stop
in the name of the law.
- Don't move. Don't move.
- Get them guns out my way.
- Freeze!
- I'm freezing!
- I'm crazy!
- And then we would go...
"Boom, boom, boom."
There's a head in that trunk,
oh, Lord
- There's a head--
- Oh, I'm bleeding.
I'm bleeding.
I hate you, Jerome.
- Why did you betray me?
- You said, "Jerome, stop."
We're not role-playing anymore,
we're playing real life.
- Why did you say Jerome?
- 'Bec..'
Well, that's my cousin's name,
it just come to me right now.
Is your cousin living
or is he dead?
He is alive,
he is alive with the Lord.
- Alive with the Lord.
- Get your ass in the car.
Hypothetically speaking
you're about to get
your salad tossed in prison.
Oh, okay, well
thank God it's hypothetical.